christopher in dallas brother what is up
how can i help you this morning
uh good morning mr delaney and
essentially what i'm calling for
is to find out if there's any hope for
my marriage or if i just need to
to cut it off and go the way of the
great d unfortunately
um my wife's got bipolar okay and she
didn't really have any issues before we
got together but for the past three
years
um she's had manic episodes which
results
in one accusations against me
for domestic abuse sexual abuse or
something along those lines
two the kids getting placed with cps and
removed from the home
and then her hospitalization anywhere
from two to three weeks to
three to four months depending on how
bad her episode is
and really i've tried everything that i
can think of we've gone to counseling
six different times um and got her set
up with a fitness trainer
you know done everything i can think of
my family's you know you need a divorcer
now my church is you must never divorce
under any circumstances and really i
just i don't know what to do
man can i just sit with you for a second
and tell you that sucks and i'm sorry
that's happening to you
yeah i hate that for you man um
bipolar is one of the most over
diagnosed
mental health diagnostics in in the
country
but when it is real it can be
devastating for entire family systems
man and i'm sorry
you said you got little kids tell me
about them
um gavin is three
wonderful we call him helper and uh so
of course he loves to help everybody and
everything he does things around the
house he loves picking up and playing
with
helping his sister and then um our
daughter her name is lyla rose we call
her keeper
um running joke there is you know we saw
her we wanted to keep her
sure she's about nine months old um
and in the past three years they've
lived with us for
a couple of for about a year they've
lived with both sets of grandparents and
even the great-grandparents
culminating for about half of gavin's
life who's three
why were they taken out of the home
well because every time there's every
time there's accusations for domestic
abuse or sexual abuse or anything like
that cps has to air on the side of
caution and remove
the children from what could potentially
be a dangerous environment
to figure out what's going on um the
first couple of times it took
longer for me to get them back because
they had to really really do an
investigation
but it seems to be taking less and less
time as this becomes more and more
frequent
sure um
and there was no validity to the
accusations or anything like that they
were just baseless what set her off
well so it's a different thing every
time um it's not it's it's
something supposedly something traumatic
which
i don't always consider traumatic but
she does and that seems to be the
important part so the first one
was um giving birth to her son
gavin the second one was us moving from
utah to texas
the third one was her niece that was
born and lived for a couple weeks and
died
um the fourth one was covid and then the
fifth one was our son got
moved from publix or from private school
to public school because he just wasn't
ready and that was the last one to set
her off
last friday and so when you say set her
off
paint me and the listeners a picture of
what a
set-off mother looks like who's
struggling with bipolar
well so it starts it's for her it's very
specific um for her
it starts with the anxiety from the
events um whatever that event is
then it goes to lack of sleep either
she's
going out and trying to cool off and
having a couple of drinks
um so she comes home 2 a.m gets up at 5
am just doesn't sleep and that right
there starts to pattern to where she
won't sleep for about a week
and then sometimes she'll make it to two
weeks with no sleep
and so what happens is she just starts
her anxiety starts building up and
building up and building up because i'm
sure
as you know you know sleep kind of
resets the mind and calms everything
down
so with her anxiety going through the
roof um the way
that it was explained to me is that when
she doesn't sleep for that long a period
of time
all the events that have ever happened
in her life are happening at once
and so she can't tell the difference
between what happened 10 years ago
and what's happening today because she's
gone so long without sleep they're all
happening to her at the same time
and so she ends up calling the police
and telling them that she was attacked
or that something like that happened
um and usually this is
usually every time it's at this event at
this stage um
i'm usually at home she's gone out
somewhere so
during this entire process she's home
maybe for
10 hours and it's hard to get her to
stay home because she doesn't want to
sit still
because her anxiety is just up up up up
up and she can't get it down
does she does she use drugs too
no she doesn't use drugs um she says she
smoked pot like once when she was like
17
but no she doesn't do any sort of drugs
or anything like that so does she
does she not take her meds will she not
take her any medications
so i still a couple of times well the
first time
when they were telling me what was going
on i was kind of getting filled in on it
they told me it was postpartum
depression so i didn't worry about her
taking men okay
um the second time she was kind of
taking mets for a little bit and using
it more as a stop gap
same thing with the third time the
fourth time um
then she she realized that things were
going on she got back on track
rather quickly and then this last time
she's been getting shots every month
so she doesn't have to take meds every
day um and she still fell off the wagon
okay so i want to do a couple of things
here
okay number one i can hear in your
voice a frustrated
exhausted don't know what to do
husband and dad okay
but i can also hear in your voice where
this has turned from
frustration to now this is a lady who's
ruining your life
and i want you to find a couple of folks
in your life that will hold you
accountable to
always keeping compassion in the front
and center of your mind and heart
okay okay um it is
true bipolar if that's really what this
is
um is just devastating but it can start
to feel like someone's attacking you
and nobody who is truly struggling from
this wants to be there
okay um and the more you can
keep yourself from attacking back the
better
now i'm going to walk you through the
next things step two here is
you have a um personal
um ethical moral spiritual any other
descriptive word you want to say you've
got a uh you've got an
obligation to take care of your children
and make sure they're safe
and it doesn't sound like they're in a
safe situation right now
um with the sporadicness mom
disappearing for
days on end weeks on end suddenly their
kids are getting ripped out of their
home to go somewhere else while dad's
being investigated for totally baseless
claims
that's going to wreak havoc on their
ability to connect it's going to be
wreak havoc
on their stability and it's going to put
you in a defensive posture
mom's totally absent i'm just telling
you right now your kids
are going to start a lifetime of
searching for connection
in all sorts of different ways okay so i
want you to
consciously start thinking about how i
can protect my kids
the third thing is this i do believe
that if this is relatively new
if you've known and i relatively knew by
a couple of years
if when y'all are dating there were no
signs of bipolar if when y'all were
y'all been together for a long time
there's no signs of bip you know y'all
been together for a while and then she
has a
challenging first birth
of your son and then this comes out
afterwards i i don't know for sure if
that's what this is
is what i'm telling you i think it is
wise if she will
and she might not that you spend the
money
you spend the time in the investment to
go meet with a
psychiatrist who knows what they're
doing who will spend not 30 minutes with
y'all
but who will spend an extended amount of
time with you guys to walk through the
history of this thing
and will give you and your family a plan
for moving forward
that's probably going to involve a
social worker who works directly with
this psychiatrist and i've seen this
work out in
a good tandem there um
and but it's going to be a team effort
moving forward
and then she's going to have to commit
to staying on the plan
um and if she doesn't she's just going
to wreak havoc in the life of those kids
and it's as you know it's very hard to
stay tethered in
and married to this sporadic-ness
i also get your till death do his part
till death do his part for sickness and
health for richer and for poor
and i get that too and so one thing you
will never hear from me
ever ever ever you will never hear from
me recommending divorce
telling someone you got to get out of
here um unless it's a very specific
specific sort of abuse situation um so
i'm not going to make that call for you
brother
i'm going to tell you you gotta gotta
take care of those kids put them number
one and keep them safe
number two if you all haven't sat down
and fully got a plan
if these shots she's taken are just from
another pcp that you went in and met
with
so be it if she's doing extended
hospitalizations my guess is she's got a
social worker and a psychiatrist that
she works with her
but you all need to go in together and
make a forever plan
that she's gonna stay on if it's truly
bipolar one of the biggest challenges
bipolar is
medication can work wonders and then
people feel really good and they quit
taking their medication and so i would i
would challenge you all to get on a plan
and then have her commit to staying on
it and then you'll begin to work on
behaviors down the road but y'all are
that's way down the road for you guys
right now we're talking about
stabilization i want you to go get a
second opinion from a different doctor
from a different psychiatrist who will
work directly with you guys and your
family
and again i want to go back to the first
thing i told you man this sucks
i wish there was an easy fix on this one
i wish there was a
oh yeah i just do this and this and this
is all gonna that's not how bipolar
works
that's not how devastating mental
illness works
that's not how being a parent with
someone that you love who's suddenly
changed and now your kids are not safe
now you're not safe that's not how this
works
and so um christopher there's not an
easy fix on this one
but it's going to be a day by day
process start with the doctor start with
taking care of your kids
one more thing i'm going to put out
there and i'm
thinking through this as i'm talking is
i want you to sit down with your parents
if her parents are in the picture sit
down with her parents and
i want you all to come up with a game
plan together if she has a couple of
friends in her life that are stable
whether that's some church friends
whether that is a sister
or a cousin that she trusts it may be a
moment for an intervention where
everybody sits down and says hey we all
have agreed that this is going to be the
plan here
one to take care of these children two
to take care of your safety
and three to do what we can to preserve
this marriage
and um getting as many people who love
her
and respect her and want her to see her
be successful and that
she trusts in some little sliver to
speak into her heart and mind
that'll help a lot that'll really help a
lot
but at the end of the day you can only
control you and you can only control
your thoughts and your actions so
default to compassion as
hard as that is brother i know that's
hard when somebody calls the cops on you
and somebody out of their own delusion
somebody out of their own sickness
gets your kids taken away for a few days
i get the rage part of that i get the
attack part of that
and you're gonna have to do some hard
spiritual searching to not default
to that because it's just going to
poison your house and at the end of the
day it's going to poison your kids man
do the best you can to default to
compassion get somebody in your life you
can be vulnerable with
and then two you got to protect those
kids you got to protect those kids and
you got to have those hard
get well conversations with your wife
we'll be thinking about you
hey man after you have this conversation
with her after you
get together with a doctor and a social
worker team y'all can kind of come up
with a plan
after you do an intervention with your
family i want you to call me back
christopher i want to hear how this goes
and um hear if she gets on the road to
healing or not or have her call me man
i'd love to talk to her directly
i'd love to talk to her directly